una sentencia que alivia este viernes un
tribunal del estado de virginia en eeuu
falló cadena perpetua para uno de los
integrantes de la célula conocida como
los beatles perteneciente al
autodenominado estado islámico la ley
que esta sentencia deje claro a todos
los que se atrevan a secuestrar torturar
o matar a cualquier ciudadano
estadounidense del extranjero que la
justicia de eeuu les encontrara donde
quiera que estén y que nuestro gobierno
les hará rendir cuentas por sus crímenes
contra nuestros ciudadanos
en el curso de la guerra siria cuatro
ciudadanos estadounidenses fueron
tomados como rehenes por esta célula
terrorista y tres de ellos fueron
posteriormente ejecutados en
decapitaciones grabadas en vídeo y
difundidas en internet el saf y el
sheikh quien recibió el castigo a cadena
perpetua este viernes es un ex ciudadano
británico al que la justicia de ese país
declaró culpable en abril por toma de
rehenes con resultado de muerte
y como muchos de ustedes saben tuvimos
que suprimir la opción de la pena de
muerte debido a las leyes británicas así
que creo que el castigo se ajusta al
crimen en este caso absolutamente por lo
que son los estadounidenses y a todos
los demás rehenes pasará el resto de sus
días en una celda y tendrá tiempo para
considerar lo que ha hecho
el site es el miembro de más alto rango
del grupo estado islámico en ser
condenado por un tribunal en eeuu sin
embargo dicho tribunal descartó pedir la
pena de muerte como parte de un acuerdo
que garantizaba su extradición